hey guys Alex here with the game spawn  news update Crytek developer Bryce on a  broom appears to be in financial trouble  according to reports on kotaku and  Eurogamer after a string of high-profile  staff departures morale has been  described as low by anonymous sources  the studio which employs them around 130  people in total has seen the departure  of over 30 staffs since the development  of homefront the revolution began one  source says that the high turnover is a  result of staff not being paid on time  on multiple occasions anonymous sources  reported to Kotaku that due to the  cancellation of a sequel to rise  employees have felt like the company of  losses directions Karthik has denied  that is in financial trouble climbing  these reports are merely unsubstantiated  rumors and reassuring fans that  development continues on home front the  revolution hunt horrors of the Gilded  Age arena of fate and war face we'll be  keeping an eye on the story on gamespot  com